back in 2017 for her federal appeals
court post
tony all right nancy thank you very much
this morning's ceremony for justice
ginsburg
is the start of a three-day formal
farewell in washington
jan crawford is outside the supreme
court for us jan good morning to you
what can we expect
well just before 9 30 this morning
justice ginsburg will
arrive here at the court for the last
time her casket is going to go up those
steps and inside the great hall of the
supreme court where there'll be a
private ceremony for her family her
close friends
the justices and some of their spouses
her casket then will be
brought out to the top of the steps
under the portico where she will
lie and repose until thursday night now
this is a change
typically a justice will lie in repose
inside the supreme court
but because of the coronavirus it will
be outside and everyone will
be required to maintain social
distancing and wear a mask
she also will line repose longer than is
usual for a justice but crowds
are already gathering uh there are going
to be thousands of people here so it's
decided that that extra day
was necessary and one of the many people
that we expect to pay their respects is
president trump just like president
obama did
in 2016 uh when he came to pay respects
uh to justice antonin scalia
conservative icon
we don't yet know if the democratic
presidential nominee joe biden
plans to travel back to washington but
the point is that today and tomorrow
this is a time and on friday
for people to put aside their political
differences and honor a justice even if
you disagreed with her
who made tremendous contribution